from the book of saw  [Music]  um  get your [ __ ] hands in the air  i ain't gonna say it again [ __ ]  [ __ ]  uh  hello detective boswick i want to play a  game  the three train is arriving in two  minutes  it is up to you to decide if this will  be your final stop  you have taken the witness stand many  times and reloaded innocent people with  your lies putting them away in jail  today it is you who will be railroaded  you have one chance to live tear from  your mouth the tongue that has so  often been used to light and to deceive  take a leap of faith and you will live  only your weight will rip away your  lying tongue and save you  live or die make your choice  [Applause]  uh  ugh  [Music]  from the book of song rated r in  theaters friday